pousser toujours plus loin les limites
du corps humain à travers des missions
extrême à travers le monde au service de
la science et de la médecine facile la
vie que même l'explorateur scientifiques
français stéphane les vins conjointe à
toulouse en france dont jour monsieur
les vaincre bon je me suis derrière vous
avez parcouru une bonne partie de la
terre je crois bien il ya quelques
années que vous avez pas assez
121 jours en autonomie totale sur la
banquise arctique mais là pour 2019
on oublie le froid vous vous préparer à
affronter la chaleur extrême
expliquez-nous est ce qui vous attend
demain 19 mai à écouter ça va être le
pendant de ce que j'ai fait dans le très
très froid dans le très très chaud le
désert du namib en namibie
l'un des déserts les plus chauds de la
planète et je le prépare à cette
expédition a passé 121 jours en
solitaire température au sol 70° des
bouffées d'air à 45 50 55 degrés peut
taire et puis les deux grands défis
l'adaptation physiologique dans ces
conditions extrêmes et puis le défi
technologique validée des technologies
des drones des robots de l'imagerie
satellite de la télémédecine des
matériels dont on a qualifié les
adaptations dans ces milieux là l'ours
est justement un explorateur
scientifique dit au plus précisément
qu'est ce que vous cherchez à démontrer
à vérifier dans ce voyage qui s'en vient
lorsque quelqu'un d'important pour moi
c'est l'extrême et de loupe de la
normalité c'est-à-dire que mes
expéditions à l'instar des compétitions
de formule 1 qui préfigure les voitures
de monsieur ou madame tout le monde dans
les semaines les mois les années qui
viennent
permettent d'observer des processus
physiologiques qui serviront la la
médecine des des protocoles des
thérapies particulier alors par exemple
dans le froid on avait permis de
comprendre que le froid le frais compris
but à l'endormissement pour des
personnes qui avaient des insomnies
d'endormissement et on va faire la même
chose dans le désert du namib sur l'état
protocole lié au cardio pulmonaire à
l'âge
lyon au stress au sommet à la l'audition
également tout à parti physiologie il
perd près la partie environnementale
delhi demandé plus de données dans ce
désert l'a très certainement liée aussi
aux grands problèmes de changement
climatique
donc c'est un voyage qui se fait assez
chargé un bagage j'imagine ne vous devez
récolter tout c'est toutes ces données
physiques tout au cours de ses 121 jours
alors pour tout vous dire on va on va
installer une comme une base spatiale en
fait parce que cette mission dans ces
conditions extrêmes
à la demande de certaines agences
spatiales le préfigure une réflexion
concrète sur la la pré installation de
base sur la lune mais également de
nombreux protocoles techniques et
médicaux qui pourront être ensuite
testées et validées pour la station
spatiale internationale
donc effectivement c'est une véritable
base qu'on te promet d'installer dans ce
désert ou intéressant à votre dernier
ouvrage va sortir le 23 janvier prochain
c'est au canada il s'appelle métier
explorateurs scientifique c'est tout cas
commun devient ton explorateurs dans des
conditions extrêmes comme vous avez
choisi de le faire
alors c'est sûr qu'à deux c'est un
parcours de vie est très engagé que ce
soit le sport le sport de haut-niveau
l'armée également
et puis parcourt tous azimuts comme
obliger justement on est en fait de
trois fois le tour de la planète
je voudrais un petit peu plus de goût de
piment à ce parcours et c'est un peu un
concours de circonstances je dirais qui
m'a décidée afin d'explorer sion mes
deux passions utile c'est-à-dire que dès
les premières missions
j'ai souhaité mettre mon organisme et
puis la technologie aussi pour que ce
soit étudiée au service du plus grand
nombre
voilà ce qu'est ce que ça prend pour
être pour faire ce que vous faites une
condition physique et mental
exceptionnel j'imagine beaucoup de
préparation effectivement cessé entre
une un an et demi et deux ans de
préparation physique de techniques de
visualisation mentale de gestion du
stress pour contribuer à aller au bout
de ses expéditions là et puis après il
ya toute une partie compréhension des
prêtres des protocoles médicaux
scientifiques et techniques qu'on me
confie c'est à dire maîtriser totalement
les mathari
les technologies et surtout après pour
partager avec le plus grand nombre c'est
à dire envoyer de mai des informations
et puis au retour les thèses qui vont
être faits les qualifications les
publications officier sur les matériels
et sur l'organisme
donc ça va bien au delà d'assouvir votre
curiosité personnelle vraiment vous en
fait profiter bien des champs
d'activités dites nous c'est pourquoi ce
grand départ
alors le départ sera très certainement
en 2020 2012 2020 on va arrêter la date
une fois que toute la partie du
financement soit bouclé parce que c'est
toujours le long parcours de
l'exploration moderne c'est-à-dire la
levée des fonds des partenaires les
sponsors et je me réjouis d'avoir toute
une équipe québécoise canadienne
mobiliser autour du programme et puis
des scientifiques que l'on va embarquer
outre atlantique est visiblement faut
pas avoir peur de la solitude quand même
121 jours comme ça en autonomie totale
stéphane des vins merci beaucoup on
comprend que cette année sera une année
de préparation on va suivre bien sûr à
votre prochain voyage merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin
merci monsieur verra combien tout revoir